-Welcome, welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everyone.
You're here, you made it.
Thank you for tuning in.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Well, guys, we are coming to you
after President Biden's
very first State of the Union
address.
Yep, it was historic.
400 representatives,
100 senators,
and size 96 font
on the teleprompter.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, it's amazing.
That's right, Biden was at
the podium with Kamala Harris
and Nancy Pelosi
right behind him.
Fox News was like,
"Throw in Hillary
and you got all Four Horsemen."
[ Laughter ]
During his speech, Biden
introduced his new unity agenda.
Unity agenda, yeah.
And you can tell it worked
'cause every single Republican
ignored him.
Meanwhile, before his
State of the Union,
Biden had a 30-minute call with
Ukrainian President Zelenskyy.
Yeah, Zelenskyy asked Biden
to share weapons
and Biden asked Zelenskyy
to share his approval rating.
[ Laughter ]
It's a good deal.
At the same time Zelenskyy
and Biden were talking,
Putin and Trump were on
their own phone call like,
"You think they're
talking about us?
They're totally
talking about us. I know."
Well, as the war continues,
I read that 12 Russian diplomats
were expelled from the U.S.
and sent back to Russia
after being accused of spying.
[ Audience oohs ]
The U.S. knew they made the
right move when eight Russians
and four office plants got up
and left for the airport.
[ Laughter ]
Meanwhile, NASA said that
despite the war,
U.S. and Russian astronauts
are still working together
on the
International Space Station.
It's not great though.
Today, one astronaut was like,
"Houston, things are awkward."
[ Laughter ]
And finally,
in some lighter news,
today is Mardi Gras, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
I love it!
Doing body shots off a stranger
is a sure sign
that things are
getting back to normal.
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yep, Mardi Gras, just as the CDC
told us that we could
loosen restrictions.
It's like getting
your driver's license
then entering the Indy 500.
[ Laughter ]
I wish NBC covered Mardi Gras
like they do
the Thanksgiving Day parade.
"Let's check in with Al Roker,
who's with a topless grandmother
from Daytona. Al?"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Mardi Gras is
a day to drink and celebrate.
It's basically your liver's
dress rehearsal
for St. Patrick's Day.
We have a great show, everybody,
give it up for the Roots!
Come on!
♪♪
Thank you so much. What a fun
show we have for tonight.
But first, guys, I follow
Chef Jose Andres
on social media.
He, of course,
has this organization,
World Central Kitchen.
And he goes around,
and when there's a disaster
or people need him, he's there.
He's feeding all these people
who can't get food,
can't get access to food.
Right now, he's in Ukraine,
and it's heartbreaking.
But it's also amazing
what he's doing.
He shows up.
He shows up for people.
And so any way we can help him
help people we want to.
So tonight we thought
we'd shine a light
on World Central Kitchen.
If you can give anything,
go to wck.org.
A dollar goes a long way.
Anything you can give helps.
Thank you very much.